[Music]
are you guys bored we'll check this out
Vsauce fate Games presents Facebook the
game did you guys like something like
that we'll pop in the cartridge and
explore a hundred and fifty million
profiles avoid the dangerous murderous
pokes do that anymore choose a weapon to
ignore messages from that sweaty kid who
kept trying to hold your hand in third
grade or take a break and procrastinate
by looking at your female friends
pictures bullseye
earn feats of strength in the dungeon
levels ignore your mother's friend
request and beat the clock untagging
yourself from photos that make you look
fat oh how the H do I get out of here
you'll have to morph into the only thing
that can escape Facebook private
personal data
nice problem-solving collect power-ups
to earn the maximum of 5,000 friends and
avoid the spinning death blades of
unneeded event invites come on I don't
even live in Kansas anymore
Oh see a messed up now where are we I
think we're stuck in Friendster wait
even worse
we're in myspace Facebook the game
coming soon
ready via party bh4 hey Vsauce thank you
so much for watching this week's fake
game trailer I hadn't done one in a
while and yesterday I had the idea to do
a Facebook game so I threw this together
in the last day with my friend Todd
Womack who's the other guy who was
playing so big thanks to him if you guys
still haven't seen the first fake game
trailer I made for the Justin Bieber
game click here to watch it and as
always if you have any ideas for games
that you're sure will never get made but
still want to see a trailer for leave
them in the comments below and if I like
one a lot I might make it next week and
thank you so much for watching and stay
tuned Friday for a special edition of
nerd wars alright see you guys later
[Music]